looking at Auschwitz today it's almost
impossible to imagine the horror that
occurred here but for those who suffered
at the hands of the Nazis it's
impossible to forget men women and
children starved experimented on and
murdered 1.1 million people were killed
here gassed or placed against walls and
shots but some did survive and will
return to mark the 75th anniversary of
the camp's liberation amongst them 93
year old Alberto Israel who now lives in
Brussels he shows us the tattoo on his
arm that marked him out as a Jew in
Auschwitz that along with the mental
scars will last a lifetime baby what a
fool I can't impose I can't what's up
Papa gobo Puerto me that's your ski tour
there is pepper I've got to ski Shepherd
a that shows the people who finish
you'll appreciate and of course my
Alberto lost his family to the Nazis his
parents and one brother killed here at
Auschwitz the camp which became the most
potent symbol of the Holocaust a place
where age was no barrier to the
brutality all of the children bar one in
this photo were murdered the sole
survivor
Albert Reds now in his 80s he escaped
Auschwitz
only because a Catholic family in
Brussels took him in age three he became
one of the so-called enfant kashchei the
hidden children that's a picture mummy
she asked me to call her mommy and her
husband I called him daddy people who
were hiding Jews
how can I say they they were condemned
at the minimum to go to to jail but
normally there is simply shooting though
they put them against the wall so they
were really risking their life
three-quarters of Albert's family
including his father were killed at
Auschwitz
it's a place he has never wanted to
visit himself but he says it's important
to never forget what happens here was
killing on an industrial scale the
living survivors of Auschwitz are now
well into old age but many of them make
the difficult journey here not just to
remember the victims but as a warning to
future generations of where political
extremism can lead their hope is Europe
will never witness genocide again
Michele Clifford sky news ouch Fitz
Poland